[Music]
there is no choosing
it happens unconsciously automatically
naturally when i log into the game i
just know what to do to win
there can be no thought because if there
is a thought
there is a time of thought and that
means
a flaw i did play like four years
without a trophy
for the right movement to occur there
must be permanent
totally alert awareness of the entire
situation
it is that awareness itself that chooses
the right stroke
technique and body to execute it for the
first blood king brings three bloods
into the top lane
and it's all over
that's good it's fun for the viewers
right if i yell if i shout
if i say cool that's that's really fun
right it's it's
entertaining
i don't dance that's why my macarena
looks so bad
no no no
holy [ __ ] but it's so hard to kill them
together also call me the first love
king yeah
this is just so insane yeah but i don't
really need to to
to to become a full-time streamer all i
have to do is just change my team and go
to an a
then i can be a full-time streamer be
washed up
and still win lcs
i mean he's the best jungler that europe
has ever produced
period there's the zenith played still
doesn't have his flash from that earlier
fight and yankos
is on the board he gets his first kill
of the game while jankos
is just in your face 3z these battles
in 2019 when he stepped onto the world
stage with g2 esports
it was easy to forget that marcin jankos
yankowski
wasn't always a single piece of an
incredible puzzle
my gaming journey started when i started
playing dota on warcraft 3
i saw league of legends being played on
hyper tv
it's like a polish gaming station i you
know
thought to myself maybe i should try it
it was pretty fun to me
when he finally got his shot at the big
leagues in season four
it wasn't as part of a super team he had
to start
from the bottom
[Music]
in late 2013 yankos put school on the
back burner
and qualified for the eu lcs with a
polish roster
called kmt the team signed with rockcat
and made their debut in the 2014 spring
split
going on towards mr stoppable force
finds him he's already used that barrier
and he's just not enough because the
damage is pounding down
the double penetration of them is
working wonders they do manage to get
four kills for zero first game in the
lcs and first win congratulations
uh thank you like it was pretty easy
i think but even as he played his first
ever week in the eu lcs
yankos couldn't help being well yankos
did they not mean to pick lease in there
i don't think they actually wanted to
pick these sims
yeah those nexus sorry it's not lasting
long nif the last man left alive here
for alliance
is not enough to secure and save the
game for them it's rock out they go
three for one
yeah like i was supposed to pick by but
i just trolled my team a bit
the team said they were gunning for a
top five spot in the spring split and
they exceeded their own expectations
placing third behind fnatic and sk
gaming it's the game for rock out ladies
and gentlemen
they will take third place in the spring
split but a trend was already developing
for the young jungler and key to that
success was yanko's own aggressive style
which he'd modeled after the renowned
jungler diamond procs
i just don't think the passive playstyle
is good right now
and it's just so boring to watch you
know when the jungle is just farming and
when i looked at diamond
every time invading enemy jungle like
ganking everywhere killing everyone it's
just so cool to watch
as he terrorized the opposition with
sudden aggression it was clear that he
wasn't just
good he was a standout jungler in the
region even
on a team that otherwise might have been
on the relegation bubble
however going a little bit though
there's a super mega death rocky jankos
is going to come in for this one
the barrier already used the flash there
from candy panda rebelled from jankos
and he gets the finisher
while jankos was good enough to turn
heads rocket as a whole
was not well the nexus stories have
already fallen that is an open nexus now
for them to finish off they look like
they want a few more kills but they turn
their focus to it
finish off the game and move through it
to the grand final tomorrow
when it came to team fights again they
they were just so much stronger i think
sk can
almost count themselves a little bit
lucky there the rocket were also a
little sloppy with things
the team did not qualify for worlds but
jankos tried his damnedest
to drag them over the finish line this
is actually really really dangerous
thank you going lower
yankov's coming in manages to get the
kill on picking the other star might go
down as well he said double for yanktos
might be in trouble again there's still
only four members yeah
overpowered did manage to get his
ultimate rewind in there as reckless
going to get pulled in yankos over on
the back side
trying to go for someone the bomb will
be enough rekkles gets bombed as well
can they get any more yankoff steps away
from the bubble sassa is trying to get
in cambodia
he does max rage onto peking pequez down
yellowstone's gonna fall into jankos and
now cyanide
sliding into trying out by the support
and maybe get away from the chasing team
but
i don't think he's gonna another okay
and that is four men down for fnatic the
very first band from fnatic was also the
elise targeting that at yankos
and he picks up karzix in the first
round of picks from rocket
and he just delivers once again jankos
is far and away
the hard carry for rockets in spring
2015 yankos experimented with a new
more cautious play style it didn't work
even with the addition of mid laner nuke
duck the team finished eighth
and after they survived relegation
jankos decided to return to his
aggressive ways in the summer
just try to play more aggressive you
know like last speed i tried to play the
brain and it was like but you know i
should play without brain and just like
follow my instinct and just kill people
but summer 2015 was the last split
jankos would play with rock at
[Music]
before the 2019 season g2 esports was
working with a powerful roster
that yankos had helped to the world
semi-finals
but they didn't stay the course they
took that team
and supercharged it and the most
surprising change
was the addition of caps i thought g2
looked the most interesting
uh i feel like that playstyle is very
like it's like they play the same kind
of way that i want to play
they have like a very aggressive mindset
and they are okay with making mistakes
as long as they're like proactive and it
meant being in a team that for once had
plenty of carry potential
outside of the jungle i felt like in
spring split last year i was playing
very well
and i felt like in summer split we were
playing too much of funeral and i was
put on thanks a lot so i was
not as used to playing my own game but
now since we have a very good players in
our team
i'm i can choose my own champion that i
want to play
and i feel like that suits me way more
jankos had long been the best jungler to
never even see a final in the eu lcs
playoffs
a streak the g2 helped him break in
spring 2019
as they took it all are looking at the
nexus
origin they're trying to fight back but
they cannot do it origin of
crumbling to g2 europe kneels
to its champion g2 esports the world
awaits
g2 i think i was really
calming game by the end of game three
because i knew that
we will win and so right now i'm
actually done
[Music]
i'm not very emotional i'm just very
happy that we won i guess
but my eyes are on msi because
i never ever played against faker in a
serious game
and even though i'm a jungler i kind of
want to go to messiah and
play you know and at msi 2019
he had the chance to prove he was among
the world's best
golems high station players against the
only very best things in the world
and i want to represent europe uh rmsi
and i want to make us proud i don't want
to get out of groups and win
the whole thing i think it's possible i
think this team has the talent to do so
and i'm just very excited to go to korea
so
can't wait g2 esports already had plenty
of experience with disappointing
international finishes
but in 2018 they made it all the way to
world semi-finals
and expectations were higher than ever
it's very rare when you see a super team
that come in and they just gel almost
immediately
doing a good job body blocking that
shuriken making sure they can't do
anything else
and then gonna be tank at the turret
aggro here for now the shot is gonna be
easy for a shot
yankees might be able to make it two
ladies and gentlemen
for the first blood king brings three
bloods into the top lane
just five minutes in
in the early days jankos got attention
for his uncanny ability
to take advantages in the early game the
community began to idolize his knack for
securing first blood
eventually hear the moniker a first
blood
king all yankers was known for first
blood king
first blood goes over to us once again
sign an idea
he's going to be able to get the kill
back though on to zazus to trade one for
one but again
jankos first blood master red bull
taking away connects gets said he's
going to be forced to flash away
he's into the pitch follows through who
gets himself first plunge he's in
trouble jankos comes around he can just
take his time with the cocoon here he's
gonna send the spider doesn't need it
first
once again goes the yankov protect their
record
but the first blood king his style
already well established was about to
face
a new kind of challenge back in 2015
when i was still in worldcat we didn't
do well
throughout the whole year then i decided
that maybe it's time to change the
roster maybe it's time to move on and
maybe it's time to look for other
opportunities
jakos joined h2k gaming where he played
in 2016 along star 80 carrie forgiven
both players were known for being a
little cocky do you feel
right now that you have the most skill
in all the bottom lanes
by far by far i think like the real
tournament starts tomorrow because like
all the n8 teams are out
so like now it's going to be competitive
finally
both players had been at one point or
another the primary carry option
on their previous teams they both had
clearly defined playstyles that had
earned them success in the past
but it was jankos that would be forced
to adapt
with forgiveness that he would have the
same play style and he wouldn't change
it so no matter what kind of draft you
would
make you would always have to be aware
that your bottle is going to like kind
of push and try to punish your opponent
so that made the opponent jungler's
movements obvious because he had to help
his spot but like when that six turrets
fell like he was
so clueless you know like the team was
clueless and he was close what to do on
the map this didn't mean an end to
aggression but it did mean that the
creative place for which yankos was
known
were a little more predictable it also
didn't mean an end to the usual yankos
antics
yes i will
play better next time i'm sorry wait no
one's talking to you
yeah please wait your turn
i think if we kill that karis they can't
win
i expect that did you splash eh no oh my
[ __ ] god
yes fine don't worry don't worry no one
has to know that
but h2k spring showed clear issues
yankos played very well yet again making
the second all-pro team
alongside his team's top and aidy carrie
but playoffs saw h2k throw away a
semi-finals buy
and finish fourth is this
suddenly forgiven was out and freeze was
in but as h2k earned fourth place during
the summer season
freeze suffered a wrist injury that
brought forgiven back to the roster for
playoffs
their semi-final exit was good enough to
punch a ticket to worlds
what happened next surprised nearly
everyone as h2k
europe's second seed fought their way to
world's
semi-finals gonna get himself killed a
miracle looking like one but the nexus
is open
forgiven he's been exhausted they're
gonna try something here but forget it
they'll cut it out an h2k
demolish annex for their semi-final
match versus samsung galaxy
but even with good early play from the
first blood king
korea would monopolize the finals and
there's
nothing that they can do a 3-0 sweep
of europe's h2k will send samsung galaxy
to the world final but yanko's trip to
worlds
even if he was knocked out in the semis
wasn't a waste
the first blood king had learned how to
adapt his play style when needed
how to take feedback and what kind of
player he did
and didn't enjoy playing with when it
comes to like forgiven we could count on
him
except for team fights because he would
not trust anyone in the team that's how
i felt like and it was not because of
the players for sure one person i'm
certain that's
just his playstyle he just doesn't trust
me i mean not me but like everyone all
in all he was a for sure a really good
player
would i consider playing with him again
no i wouldn't want to play team again
personally
in 2019 untethered from one linear
playstyle
yankos could play his way with a team
that trusted him completely
but i think that g2 is actually more
than the sum of their parts they're
intelligent
and the fact that with that fine tooth
comb you learn more and more about what
league of legends is
and can be is to me just a huge shout
out to g2
they came in they were an incredibly
aggressive team because they knew if
there's a play being made through yonkos
everyone's rotating in on the play and
at msi
it all came together g2 esports are
teleporting into the base they're
looking for the nexus turrets with a
barren and powered minion
nexus turret number one falls next to
start number two is being focused
that's mata down teddy flashes away
that's not over yet the nexus throws
falls
ladies and gentlemen watching him aside
do you believe
g2 obliterate skt hopeful to get
something here in the midst of the fight
that's the two-man taunt cavs going to
try to end the game it could just go out
here can they do it they can't stop it
g2 come out on top g2 just walking
over flash rolls you knew it had to
happen they find the ace the nexus
right in front of in g2 three and one to
close out day two
it's gonna be a very hype and we need to
see whether or not
sk telecom or g2 esports will have a
shot at
the title wow look at caps he's coming
in from outside of vision both q's
already caught mata he's gonna fight
time mickey gets a three-man torch
captain's waiting for the ultimate for
that card throws down the maelstrom and
uses the hourglass that's a shutdown or
wonder he can't do more but it's a trade
top player for top laner another
fantastic turn from mickey
three more die in favor of g2 khan has
managed to make it to the river
capps has thrown down a one he's got
vision the claw will tag mata mickey's
gonna be in range as well there's no
flash available and he may need to
justice punch over the wall
baron has been interrupted teddy is
trying to step forward the taunt is
going to come out
captures trying to find the kill
martin's in trouble fake is low but
they've already got one at the mata
where is teddy follow his hb bar can't
blast off the water he's dead yeah cause
he's in the pit
g2 esports have been gifted and donated
a baron from skt that's a done from
wonder death from below
for the double for the ace for the baron
champions can fall gods can bleed where
were you
when the west rose up to conquer
champions
g2 esports eliminates sk
telecom welcome
to the finals of the 2009
mid season invitational and who would
have believed it was north america's
team liquid
versus europe's g2 esports
they're gonna go ooh they're going on
xmithie they know devil isn't there the
slow is there on a tom catch you can eat
it for a little bit but he's gonna be
knocked up and here comes the tvs from
everyone else they try to buy some time
according to jay
gonna die yet again no tv for doubles
instead of swain here and the gang plank
as well the barrels come out but there's
no chain
he's going to flash back to safety the
knockout's coming in they're gonna get
yet another
one a double kill for perk leave you
have five minutes until barons but the
midline is already there that bastard
defense
just being shut down one kill picked up
ready to mix 50
and look out for jensen rooted shockwave
is not going to be enough they trade one
for the end of it all and now yanko's
able to walk away up that kill
and g2 rip through the hearts of team
liquid north american fans
as they secure themselves in the top of
the world
there is no chance dl comes back from
this they're already out of the nexus
turrets
this is what peak league of legends
looks like
and it comes from europe a world
record g2 esports 3-0
will win msi 2019.
jankos and g2 did the unbelievable at
msi 2019
suddenly the gap seemed like it had
closed
and jankos was part of a team that was
breaking all the rules
even as it dominated the competition
yeah i mean
i guess it just feels pretty good to be
able to leave the trophy on
international stage this year is my
first time that i won the split in
europe
and i also own a trophy on international
stage so i'm really happy
you know to be in this team be a part of
this team and just enjoy it
jankos became a key part of the greatest
european team
in league of legends history and mvp
voters agreed
choosing him as the mvp for summer 2019
as he brought out old favorites like
elise and jarvin
thank you guys i love athens thank you
guys
thank you for voting for me i appreciate
it no problem there you go
congratulations jankos
but they had won everything in 2019
except worlds and there it wouldn't be
enough to be mechanically gifted
yankos would need the mental fortitude
to hold firm
under the highest pressures the game can
offer
2016's trip to worlds had been an
incredible if surprising step for yankos
first time of my life i could face the
best players in the world i could
you know try myself against them see if
i'm better like
what do i like still it was great it was
like probably the best year of my pro
career just
yet but though yankos was clearly one of
the best mechanical junglers in europe
he had a secret he was a tilter if you
play and you tilt and you go
with the tilt like the more basic like
you
get more mud as you play because you
drive yourself crazy so
yeah you probably should not do that
because it's useless it will not
win you the game genkos had spent much
of his early career as his team's
number one option for victory but that
meant he
also carried a big mental burden we just
counted on me getting ganks off so i
would just
have no game plan whatsoever back in
back then and i would just run around
the map and hope that i would get
kills and if i wouldn't then i would be
considered that i'm choking and i'm not
playing well right
though h2k added star mid laner febiven
it was not enough to get them close to
either a playoffs final something jankos
had yet to experience
or back to worlds it is the 3-0
it is the third seed it is fnatic back
on the world stage
despite that jankos credits h2k with
providing him something that helped him
become a better player
they arranged for sports psychologist
sessions
to work through his mental game we had a
sports biologist in
h2k so i talk to him and try to improve
my performance when it comes to
handling emotions on stage any emotions
like in scrims and
just being in my always like in my prime
or like in my zone huh so maybe that
kind of helped me as well
jagos is the greatest jungler that
europe has ever produced
but maybe it's because he did his fair
share of losing
first i remember just going out of those
series after 2017 being like you know
what
yankers actually played well
individually but the team had already
fallen apart and which is way worse than
whatever they played against
jankos could have walked away from some
of these series in 2017 and told himself
well i played fine instead he put in the
work
on his mentality it's tough because you
know it's like
a lot on your mental strength and
without mental strength you cannot
probably be the best
in the world simply because you know you
will
probably lose one or two games to like
the second best team or something and
if you you know break in those two three
games then
that's it you know you lost the whole
series because in fifth game in fourth
game in third game you will just not
perform as well as you should have but
he also received secondhand insight from
one of the game's best
when he attended all-stars 2016. what
did he say what did you talk about
what he said you know to me not to me
was that europe doesn't know how to lose
and i think this sentence is very
important doesn't know how to lose yeah
because i
do believe that korean teams when they
lose they can improve so much from it
and they don't give up on emotions
so many people in europe including me
react on emotions a lot
and that what makes it hard to like
strive for victory and you know everyone
is emotional after you lose you're down
and then
you have one or two days bad of screams
you let the loose affect you
and they don't do it you know
europe had learned to lose now it was
time for yankos to again
show faker that europe had learned to
win too
after a grueling run through groups and
an astonishing win against damon esports
in the quarterfinals yankos once again
played against
and defeated one of his idols the
greatest team
in the history of league of legends
taken down
by the greatest team europe has ever
produced
fbx get ready g2
is heading to paris jankos who had not
seen a final of any kind
in the first three years of his eu lcs
career
would play in the world's final
unfortunately it would not be the result
he hoped for
the nexus is being focused it's going
down and fun
plus phoenix are your world champions
but even as they were swept 0-3 by fun
plus phoenix
the mentality on stage was vintage
yankos
as they were completely blown out in the
second game they did something that many
didn't expect and some
even maligned they laughed it off
guys i really like that we are embracing
it at this point
we are really like having fun right now
and though yankos didn't lift the
summoner's cup
he didn't let the loss slow him down he
was an important part of the team's
fourth straight european championship
he was the lec spring 2020 mvp a second
split in a row the yankosa split
mvp at just an indomitable performance
by g2 they were
exceptional from start to finish and
most importantly
he was still yankos i do
feel like i'm you know super old for a
pro player because i'll be 25 this year
but at the same time as long as i don't
play really bad or
i can like keep up like a high level and
g2 doesn't actually kick me for a
younger player
i want to leave g2 i would probably give
g2 for
um not necessarily for a better team
right but i'm not
killing and winning so i'm happy
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages